Avengers: Endgame took secrecy to all new
levels with its intentionally spoiler-free
marketing efforts.
Once the movie was released, though, the behind-the-scenes
info began pouring out.
Here are some of the most interesting things
to emerge.
It's a well-known fact that directors Joe
and Anthony Russo will go to extreme lengths
to keep their Marvel creations under wraps.
For example, they teasingly apologized to
the spoiler-prone Tom Holland for dusting
Spidey at the end of Infinity War and consequently
keeping him at arm's length for the promotion
of Endgame.
They also pretended to fire Mark Ruffalo after
a string of spoilers had put him on thin ice.
One of the best methods for keeping everyone
in the dark, though, was the way the Russos
handled the script.
Most of the actors only got pieces of the
screenplay to work from, and apparently, Ruffalo
got a particularly spoiler-proof version of
the script.
The Hulk actor was only given a partial script
with additional dummy scenes in it, according
to an interview with E! News:
"I don't know what's gonna happen.
I shot like five different endings.
I didn't even get a whole script for this
movie."
But even that didn't stop him from accidentally
giving something away.
In that same interview, he joked about what
he presumably thought was one of those "dummy
scenes."
The spoiler?
"He gets married in this!"
"They have to throw Mark off the scent."
Oops…
Endgame is the second MCU outing for Carol
Danvers, who arrived on the scene just weeks
earlier in her own superhero flick, Captain
Marvel.
For actress Brie Larson, though, that wasn't
the case.
Larson had filmed her scenes for Endgame before
she ever had a chance to flesh out the character
in her own film.
As an added twist, the first scene she ever
filmed was set during the events of Endgame,
but technically ended up in Captain Marvel.
On The Tonight Show, Larson recalled that
her first day of filming was for the end credit
scene for her own film, which showed her arriving
at the Avengers facility post-snap.
"Whip pans to me and I go, 'Where's Fury?'
I didn't know that was the tag for Captain
Marvel.
I didn't know what that was that we were shooting.
There was also no one else there."
In true Russo fashion, though, the actress
was only given her lines and filmed her part
alone in front of a green screen.
That's taking secrecy to a whole new level.
While the Russo brothers bent over backwards
to keep actors like Ruffalo, Holland, and
Larson from spoiling the script, there was
one person that they didn't mind showing the
whole thing to: Robert Downey Jr.
While discussing Infinity War and Endgame
in an interview with Rotten Tomatoes, the
pair talked about keeping things secret:
"RDJ was probably the only one to actually
read the entire script."
"Evans might have read the script."
"Part of our motivation to do that is that
it just takes a lot of pressure off of people."
Everything had started with Iron Man just
a decade earlier.
With Endgame ultimately serving as the Iron
Avenger's swan song, it's only appropriate
that RDJ would be trusted with some of the
most sensitive MCU knowledge to ever exist.
When the Avengers break into teams for their
time heist in Endgame, Rocket and Thor are
sent to Asgard during the events of Thor:
The Dark World to retrieve the Reality Stone.
At that point in time, the Stone is using
the God of Thunder's ex, Jane Foster, as a
host.
Foster, who's been absent from Marvel films
since The Dark World, appears onscreen a few
times before Rocket is able to get the Reality
Stone out of her.
But it turns out that Foster actress Natalie
Portman didn't actually film any new footage
for Endgame.
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
the Russos explained that they had been able
to salvage unused footage from The Dark World
in order to get all of the scenes they needed.
While the footage was enough for them to work
with, they did ask the actress to record a
small bit of voice-over.
In the days after Endgame lit up the theater
marquees, Star-Lord actor Chris Pratt stirred
up attention by releasing a video he'd taken
on set while preparing for one of the film's
key action sequences.
The once-in-a-lifetime video showed nearly
all of the famous actors, mostly in sweats
and comfortable clothing, chatting and discussing
their scenes as casually as if they were a
group of high schoolers hanging out after
class.
The video gave a unique glimpse into the inner
workings of a film that had been kept tightly
under wraps since day one.
Stan Lee was a comic book titan for over half
a century.
While he was an important creative mind behind
the scenes for decades, his long relationship
with Marvel also led to a memorable series
of fan-favorite cameos throughout various
Marvel movies.
When Lee passed away in late 2018, fans began
theorizing about when his last cameo would
surface.
A year earlier, it had been revealed that
Lee had filmed five different cameos for upcoming
films.
The fact that he was apparently batching his
cameos naturally left the possibility that
he could be popping into films for an indefinite
amount of time.
Endgame delivered a shot of a younger-looking
hippie version of Lee driving by the 1970's
S.H.I.E.L.D.
headquarters shouting, "Make love, not war!"
As it turned out, that scene will be Lee's
last ever cameo, and it's a fitting farewell.
The Russos confirmed after the fact that it's
the last Stan Lee cameo that made it to film.
In a twist that few people saw coming in Endgame,
Natasha Romanoff ended up sacrificing herself
for the Soul Stone.
It was a beautifully redemptive way to end
her own heroic story, which had been going
on in the background for nearly the entire
MCU.
But, of course, this is Marvel, and there's
always the question of whether they'll bring
her back.
With Gamora's re-entrance into the future
from the past in Endgame, anything is possible.
Except, not with Romanoff her story seems
closed for good this time.
Screenwriters Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely explained to The New York Times:
"Her journey, in our minds, had come to an
end if she could get the Avengers back.
[...] She has a chance to get [them] back,
that's a thing she would trade for."
During her memorial scene on the dock, the
surviving heroes' conversation drove home
the point that the cost of the Soul Stone
is a permanent one.
While there's no doubt that Black Widow will
be remembered by fans for years to come, she's
gone for good except, presumably, for her
upcoming movie.
While Black Widow may have ultimately been
given a powerful closing to her own story,
Romanoff's death wasn't always a sure thing.
After all, movies aren't completely finished
until the release date.
The shawarma end credit scene from Avengers
wasn't even added until the week that the
film was released.
So it should come as no surprise that there
was a lot of shifting and changing as they
went along.
One of those changes?
The events on Vormir.
Writers Markus and McFeely explained that
there was a version of the script that had
Clint Barton sacrificing himself for the stone
instead of Romanoff.
But when they gave the scene to the visual
effects producer Jen Underdahl, she apparently
told them:
"Don't you take this away from her."
The response clearly impacted the writers,
who ultimately acknowledged that it had to
be Romanoff.
It turns out that Markus and McFeely have
had a working "master document" since Captain
America: Civil War, where they kept track
of different things they wanted to do with
their heroes' character arcs.
It turns out that Endgame was the movie where
they got to run wild.
In particular, McFeely said that they wanted
to explore Marvel's tradition of "What If"
comics alternate universe presentations of
Marvel events playing out differently.
The writers dove in and incorporated a bunch
of "what if" scenarios right into the Endgame
plot.
The writers told The New York Times:
"Well, this is our What If?
If you lost, Thor becomes fat.
Natasha becomes a shut-in.
Steve becomes depressed.
Tony gets on with his life.
Hulk is a superhero.
[...] Clint becomes a murdering maniac."
While there were solid reasons for every character's
shift in tone, there's no doubt that the writers
were happy to push the heroes out of their
comfort zones for the entertainment of all.
Infinity War and Endgame may be two distinctly
different movies, but the subject matter that
they handle is clearly interwoven.
This left the writers and directors constantly
scrambling to figure out how to puzzle a bunch
of different pieces of storyline together
in a coherent way that left them with two
distinct yet connected movies.
At one point, the plan was to have Hulk and
Banner resolve their differences in Infinity
War.
However, it felt like too much of a positive
in the middle of a pretty sad ending, so the
filmmakers bumped it to Endgame.
They also left out the actual transformation,
banking on Scott Lang in the diner scene to
provide the right amount of confusion to help
bridge the gap.
In the same vein, Hawkeye's opening scene
in Endgame where he loses his family was nearly
tacked onto the end of Infinity War, but it
once again felt out of place.
The biggest decision of all was where to place
the Snap.
They debated putting it earlier in Infinity
War, but it would have left almost nothing
for the ending.
On the other hand, if they pushed it to Endgame,
it would have left the first movie with no
ending at all.
Knowing when to reverse the Snap was nearly
as challenging.
Thankfully, the creative minds behind the
scenes managed to eventually pull it all together
into two coherent stories.
Scott Lang was right Endgame is a time heist
movie.
It wasn't the writers who came up with that
one, though, but Marvel boss Kevin Feige himself.
Feige's original suggestion was to use time
travel to resolve the Infinity War plot, with
the centerpiece being the Time Stone.
It wasn't until the filmmakers began fleshing
things out that the Quantum Realm became the
key plot device to move the time travel element
forward.
Once time travel was in the mix, there was
one obvious point that had to make it into
the film: the Battle of New York.
But the writers initially felt it was too
"pander-y" to head to the original Avengers
film, so they tried a ton of alternatives
first.
At one point, they had Tony Stark on Asgard
in a stealth suit fighting Heimdall, and the
planet Morag was originally underwater.
At another point, the Avengers stopped by
Triskelion and even hopped in a car to visit
Dr. Strange.
When the rubber hit the road, though, writers
and directors alike finally decided that heading
back to the Chitauri-infested streets of New
York was the best option of the bunch.
The sequence in Endgame when our heroes put
their heist plan to the test shows that time
travel within the MCU is distinctly different
than the way it's been represented in movies
like Time Cop, Hot Tub Time Machine, or Back
to the Future.
"Doc.
Are you telling me that you built a time machine
out of a DeLorean?"
It also establishes that Pym particles are
in extremely limited supply.
Tony Stark and Steve Rogers head back on a
potentially one-way trip to the '70s in the
hope of scrounging up more particles just
to keep everything from falling apart.
This left fans scratching their heads when
Nebula casually brought Thanos' entire planet-sized
ship and its massive army into the present.
Where on Earth did they get the impossibly
huge number of particles to pull off a stunt
like that?
Joe Russo cleared up the disconnect in an
interview, offering an elegantly simple solution.
When 2014 Nebula surrenders the Pym particles
to her father, they aren't for him to use
to time travel; they're for scientific research.
Thanos, a genius himself, with the help of
the powerful sorcerer Ebony Maw, studied the
Pym particles and then mass-produced them
in order to defeat the Avengers once and for
all.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Avengers
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.